10h21 à trois kilomètres du centre ville
de toulouse
de très fortes explosions séparées de
quelques secondes proviennent de l'usiné
chimique azf classé zone seveso
c'est-à-dire zone dangereuse
le souffle est énorme ressenti d'abord
sur la voie rapide toute proche
les automobilistes sorte hagard parfois
blessés de leur voiture très endommagée
à quelques mètres de là l'usiné qui
fabrique des engrais est évacué
on la lui l'explosion on s'est tous
retrouvés dans l'état où on est là je ne
peux pas vous en dire plus pour
l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les blessés et j'ai fait
évacué à l'hôpital marchant qui est à
côté
la plupart des gens valides parce que
nous avons potentiellement un problème
de gaz de fuite de gaz dans l'usiné
l'explosion a détruit deux bâtiments
industriels long d'une centaine de
mètres chacun les dégâts sont
considérables dans toulouse même c'est
la panique
gêné par les embouteillages les secours
se rendent sur place sur les trottoirs
on improvise les premiers soins la
population est sous le choc
juste à côté juste avant vous vous
exposez et je me suis retourné j'ai vu
des panneaux routiers dans le ciel et et
en gras sont faits
selon des témoins 20 30 secondes après
l'explosion un nuage s'est élevée au
dessus de l'usiné
une forte odeur d'ammoniac s'est
immédiatement répondu sur toulouse la
protection civile a demandé aux
habitants de rester confinés chez eux
deux heures après l'accident un premier
bilan a été dressé
il y aurait dix morts 130 blessés dont
trois graves